so the biggest change that we're making
right away and taking King is your light
level is being brought in and
grandfathered in as your character level
so your level 34 on the left side there
yeah is now your character level I mean
this is what you earn by increasing XP
if you're a level 34 or a level 32 or a
level 30 any character from year one
when you first log in to 2.0 yeah well
grandfather your character in and well
basically just boost you up to the level
that you always have been all through
the last last year so how are you
calculating this level for this level 34
character we're gonna take a look at the
gear that's on all your characters in
your vault like just all over the place
and we'll figure out where your best
character would be so okay you don't
have to worry about anything like you
know logging in the night before and
equipping the right stuff so that you
actually are level 34 when you start
tanking everything in my inventory
everything in my vault yep put it
together into big mathematical atom
smasher we determine your level
protip for you at home don't dismantle a
thing before this game comes out guys
we're gonna take stock of what you have
and we're gonna determine what level
your character is so how does this go up
so this is simple experience I mean you
can play patrols you can do strike so
you can play crucible like anything
that's hurting your XP is gonna bring
your level up so this is this is just
like reaching level 20 was in year 1 and
you know in taking King the level cap
increases to 40 so you'll be able to
level up get access to new gear new
equipment and pretty pretty simple the
key here is that anyone who plays the
game just by playing and killing
monsters finishing activities can hit
the max level now yeah okay so on the
right side we have your light yes so in
year 1 this was sort of buried on
certain pieces of armor and you never
really saw this stat but it was like the
most important thing for you know
getting into the deeper endgame so now
this is visible on your top level of
character screen it's actually just a
product of all your gear now instead of
being a single stat on like just a
COMPETES of armor so if you look at a
helmet for example or you see you've got
190 defense and
defense an attack they both just combine
together it's kind of an average and
okay shows up on your character says the
right level is an average of my attack
and defense on my entire character
that's right so all of these 190 items
the average would be 190 so what's
bringing me down right now 86 might have
a bad item equipped on whether your
slots or something like that see yeah
you just got to go show which is a bit
lower level and girls have like now yep
ghosts of light now your class lot has
light now these are all contributing
towards making your character stronger
so there's you know there's more there's
more to pursue there's you're not just
doing a raid for like one of four slots
that actually matter everything matters
know everything is helpful for your
character everything you do progresses
you everything that you do contributes
to a higher level if I'm a guy who and I
am filthy casuals of the world unite if
I'm a guy who likes to go out of patrol
while I enjoy the company of some
friends if I like to go into the
crucible and fail miserably with people
who are better at the game than myself I
will reach that level cap yeah you will
reach level 40 absolutely
you always tell an interesting story
about what was it the meme of forever 29
yeah like last year you know it does
happen to a lot of people were when with
light level was the thing that you
chased it wasn't in your control right
like you had to get the boots was it in
the raid to shoot about 30 and the
difference between level 30 and level 29
was pretty substantial and now like
light is a three-digit number and you
know 9 or 10 different items can
contribute to it and like what why is
that number so important so for example
in this case in year 1 going from 29 to
30 I mean that was something like a 30%
swing and how much damage you didn't
took and we had a big big difference the
light is more granular now so you can
make a little bit of progress you know
you like to say it's nice to go on and
bump things up by one step like you
don't have to wait several weeks for a
drop that is not happening for you feel
like maybe there's a more logical path
between me and my next leveling up so as
I level up more as I reach higher levels
of orders
magnitude what does that do for me so
once you hit level 40 you're capped but
that's what's going to give you access
to some of the better gear that's
available you have a few pieces of this
in your inventory right now so like
here's a level 40 item that you know is
280 defense or when you get to level 40
and you're able to equip that you're
gonna see a nice big bump in your light
level right so for you at home that is
equipped for demonstration purposes only
you're not gonna walk into the tower on
your first day with endgame gear these
Legendary's are things that you'll
acquire in playing to taken King content
but it won't be available to you until
you level up to level 40 here's
something else I want to ask because it
looks like you're doing some some
different things here we still have
intellect and discipline and strength
yep
so strengths for example because your
melee ability is unlocked on this test
character it's showing you what your
actual cooldown for that ability is
going to be discipline and intellect
test character not unlocked yet but all
these will show you how many seconds
like your cooldown it actually is
instead of just being sort of a weird
percentage number that you really just
kind of get this has made me really
value gear a lot more like it you know
in the in destiny one in the live game
right now i I see discipline I see until
I see strength and it says the ads gonna
speed this thing up but I never know how
much so like I kind of just don't care
about it but now I can see hey I just
equipped this item and I went from 55
seconds to 48 yeah and I'm like well you
know I love the stormcaller and his new
super is incredible and so I'm gonna
maximize intelligence like I'm looking
for a gear that has intelligence so I
can cast my super as fast as possible as
frequently as possible
you